your mama's so short you can see her
legs while her driver's license oh
that's funny you kids yo mama's so
stupid she thought seaweed was something
that fish smoked your mama's so ugly
when she looked out her window she got
arrested for mooning yo mama so old she
sat next to Moses in third grade but see
I think Moses was a slave so like I
don't think Moses ever really got
educated your mama Saddam she stared at
orange juice for 30 minutes because it's
concentrate yo mama's so ugly hello
kitty said goodbye I like that one
bye [ __ ] your mama's so old when I told
her to act her age your mama so ugly her
reflection said I quit these are too
clean there could be like I wouldn't
give mama something like that keep me in
the same ones yeah that's the thing I
need my glasses
your mama's so blind I don't see your
mama so stupid she got fired from M&M
factory for throwing out the W's their
M&Ms that have double e's yo mama's so
ugly when she came out of the haunted
house she had an application down
to the point where she working at a
haunted house for free minimum wage whoo
your mama's so stupid when Terminator
said I'll be back
I would wait for our nurse Watson II
gotta be honest with you yo mama's so
stupid she thinks a quarterback is a
refund that's a good one like getting my
quarterback right
give me my quarterback they need to be
more 21st century jokes you know more
gender equality type of your mama your
mama looks like your papa
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part